There's a story floating around about Elizabeth
Warren that has her taking a lot of heat from
people on the left because she made one point
$9 million over 30 years doing legal consulting
work for a number of different corporations.
Now let me, I don't even know.
I, I don't even know why I do this.
I know I'm going to get crushed, but I'll
do the normal disclaimers.
I'm not endorsing Elizabeth Warren.
I'm not defending Elizabeth Warren's particular
work in any of the cases we're going to discuss.
But what I am here to tell you is I think
that some of the critiques around this are
a little bit misplaced.
Some people are saying that this Warren thing
is a story of misogyny, that Elizabeth Warren
is being slammed for making one point $9 million
over 30 years.
Whereas you have people like Michael Bloomberg
spending 30 million on his own campaign and
nobody questions it.
Nobody questions bayzos his income, whatever.
That that's, there's a an identity politics
thing that's being said about this.
There are others who are saying this is really
about corporate cronyism, centrists status
quo politics and Elizabeth Warren not as a
progressive but rather as a tool of the centrist
corporate establishment.
So once again, disclosure, this is not an
endorsement of Elizabeth Warren.
This is a warning that we should pick our
battles and pick battles that make sense,
particularly within the framework of the democratic
primary.
So let's go through the facts.
The report is that Elizabeth Warren put out
a detailed compensation list, partially because
of pressure from the Pete Buddha judge campaign
and it was revealed that she worked for about
30 years as a legal consultant.
There were cases that she worked on as a consultant
while she was teaching law, mostly at Harvard
and at the university of Pennsylvania.
Now Elizabeth Warren is an expert in bankruptcy.
A lot of the cases related to bankruptcy make
sense.
And in total it was one point $9 million in
income over 30 years.
So number one, this is about $63,000 a year.
Now, there's no question that Elizabeth Warren
is hugely privileged.
We knew that back when she ran for Senate
and I interviewed her in person.
I said, you know, you have rhetoric that is
one thing, and at the same time you are very
wealthy yourself.
She's, her net worth is known to be around
10 to $12 million.
Now I think it was more in the single digits
then.
I think she's made a lot of money from, from
books and maybe speaking since, I'm not totally
sure, but we've known that Elizabeth Warren
has a lot of money for a very long time.
What I hate to break to people is that earning
$63,000 in extra income per year doing legal
consulting when you are a relatively well
known and respected law professor is not shocking.
It is not a crazy amount of money when we're
talking about Bloomberg and Trump and bayzos
and, and you know, Sheldon Adelson and all
of this stuff.
Elizabeth Warren over 30 years making 63 grand
a year doing legal work, which is what lawyers
do.
It's really not a scandal.
Now, um, you can say some of the specific
people she represented are problematic.
Okay.
Now you've got a little bit better of an argument.
She represented a company called LTV steel
or consulted for them who didn't want to pay
into a fund for coal miners.
She was on the wrong side of that.
The progressive thing to do is you support
the miners.
She was hired by LTV steel and she represented
them.
Can we go after her for that?
Sure.
In the same way that you can go after a defense
attorney for representing someone that you
think is guilty, that's fair game.
That's just a question of what do we think
about lawyers?
She advised Dow chemical about some breast
implant litigation and made 20 grand for that.
It was Dow chemical on the side of people
who had been hurt by their breast implants.
No, she wasn't, and we can criticize her for
that.
She advised one of Enron's creditors.
Remember Enron imploded and lots of people
lost money.
She advised one event runs creditors.
Most of the cases were pretty mundane and
they never made headlines.
Now let's discuss the talking points that
are floating around.
There are memes floating around about, wow,
a woman earns 2 million over 30 years.
Oh my goodness.
Meanwhile, Mike Bloomberg spends 35 million
in two weeks on his campaign and no one bats
an eye.
First of all, people are talking about how
much money Bloomberg is spending, so I don't
think that it's fair to say there's not reporting
about that, but I don't think it's about male,
female in particular here.
I think it's about expectations.
Bloomberg is held to a different standard.
He is a billionaire buying his way into this
race.
Elizabeth Warren is rightly seen as someone
closer to Bernie, but with a more corporate
pass.
There's no question.
So I think this is the wrong area of focus.
I don't think that this reveals anything new
about Elizabeth Warren.
I am very concerned and have been about her
association with someone named Susie Orman
who is a sort of financial pop finance person
who gives some kind of weird advice that's
not new, but this entire 1.9 million earnings
over 30 years was pushed by the Buddha judge
people and ultimately I don't think we've
really learned much from it on PR on policy.
Bernie remains the most progressive.
Elizabeth Warren is a close second.
We know Bernie got to where he is politically
from a hippie activist past in Brooklyn and
Vermont.
Elizabeth Warren, on the other hand, has been
pulled left politically coming from a more
centrist, status quo, legal, political, corporate
world.
And, uh, we deal with their policy proposals
as they are today, period.
And I don't think this is the right story
for the left to go crazy over.
If I'm wrong, let me know.
And no, I have not endorsed Elizabeth Warren
in this segment.